this is sydney kennen
she's flying on a jet of air traveling
at over 100 miles per hour
she's one of the world's best indoor
skydivers and she's only 14.
it kind of feels like the matrix i'm
pretty much defying gravity
sydney holds numerous top prizes at
competitions all around the world
she's been the u.s junior national
champion three years in a row
and she holds a guinness world record
the world record i have
is the most box split spins in a minute
in the wind tunnel i got
68 in total i was a little dizzy because
it was for a whole minute straight
but usually i don't really get dizzy in
there for sydney
taking skydiving outside of the tunnel
doesn't appeal as much as you might
think
i might want to skydive when i'm older
it's five years away so i might change
my mind
i'm also kind of scared of heights
at right field at the headquarters of
the air materiel command
aeronautical engineers are working on
problems of research and development
this is one of the first wind tunnels
built in 1945.
it's also where aircraft machinist and
skydiver jack tiffany
became the first person to fly in a wind
tunnel
early wind tunnels built for human
flight featured the fan below the
skydiver
in 1997 the fans were moved above and
the chamber was enclosed
this is known as an open flow system but
it wasn't until 2005
that the modern wind tunnels like this
one were born
this building houses a recirculating
system that is key to the modern
vertical wind tunnel
there are four giant fans at the top of
the chamber
12 feet in diameter that pull the air up
the air is recirculated back down these
two shafts and then
back up again this allows for turbulent
free
controllable wind many say the sensation
is very similar to the real thing
if you move your arm a little bit you'll
like turn or go to the side
and if you like straighten your legs and
arms at the same time you'll go up
and if you like bend them you'll go down
the wind speeds can be cranked up to 185
miles an hour
everyone has their own unique wind speed
that they fly at
what my main wind speed is around like
10 115 maybe but i can fly up to like
the highest speeds in almost all the
tunnels
higher wind speeds allow you to make
quicker moves but don't expect to start
out at this level
you have to make pretty small body
movements
because the higher wind speed affects it
more wind speeds also
they can be affected by what you're
wearing so if you're wearing a baggier
suit you'll be at a lower wind speed
because there's more drag
but if you're wearing a tighter suit
which most freestylists do
you're usually at a higher speed
there are four basic body positions in
indoor skydiving
the first one you're pretty much laying
on your belly you have your arms spread
out
and your legs spread out the instructor
will tell you to like bend your legs or
straighten your legs to move you and you
can also
turn your like use your hands to turn
and also use your feet to turn
and they don't have to be big movements
at all small movements go a long way
the second one you would learn is back
flying
so you're kind of sitting in a chair but
on your back you can use your feet to
turn your hands to turn
you can go flat to go up and scrunch up
to go down
the third would be sit which is you're
sitting in a chair and you have your
arms at like a 90 degree angle
you can straighten your legs to go back
and bend them to go forward
and the last one that you would learn
would be head down
you can use your head to turn this time
and
your arms and legs are turned again and
then you can straighten your legs
to go up and bend them to go down that
one took me the longest to learn
it's really hard because everything's
upside down which is kind of difficult
to
know where you are in the tunnel
sydney competes in a number of different
categories such as freestyle
where competitors create their own
routines
other categories include formation
skydiving a more traditional approach to
the sport
and dynamic where teams of two or even
four skydivers
are judged off specific sequences that
they must perform
with freestyle every move in your
routine counts
from the second you enter the door
i try to do as many hard and difficult
tricks in my routine
as i can while keeping it pretty and
smooth and graceful
sydney has big goals she hopes this
sport will soon qualify for the olympics
so she can compete for a gold medal but
it hasn't yet caught on
outside of a niche community some of the
challenges are like
trying to explain to people that it's
actually a sport because
a lot of people think it's just like a
fun amusement ride but they don't really
realize that
it takes a lot to be an indoor squad
ever
the first time i started flying was when
i was four years old
yeah buddy i was super nervous
sydney took classes when she first
started but she quickly outgrew them as
her skills progressed
it just like set me up for my main body
positions and stuff and i started
training on my own
sydney doesn't have her own coach so her
parents help when they can
i haven't had a coach in a long time a
lot of people have like access to really
nice coaches
so pretty much my coaches are me my mom
and my dad
my mom and like me talk a lot in like
sign language or weird like
signs about like what's working and
what's not working in my routine
she finds unique ways to train outside
of the tunnel so she can stay at the top
of her game
outside i do a lot of stretching and
trampolining
and contortion she uses her training to
create new tricks
like this one she calls the scorpion one
of the contortion moves that i learned
was where you can touch your feet to
your head so i was like maybe i can do
this in the tunnel maybe i'll just try
it
i remember trying it and trying and
trying it and like one of the last
rotations i had i finally just like
tapped my head and i was like oh yeah
this is amazing
classic sydney scorpion moves in 2018
for nationals i got into the last round
and i was just like you know what i'll
just do a scorpion maybe
i'll win so i got first for best trick
off of that which is pretty cool
sydney trains hard two times a week she
goes to the tunnel
after school and applies her gymnastic
work to her flying
so it's like it's pretty long days
because then i also have to do
homework and like i like want to talk to
my friends sometimes and stuff
my most memorable moment my first
competition
even though i wasn't very good i knew
like i want to do this this is
what i want to do for a long long time